So,
um,
last time we talked,
I started to walk you through the
nervous system a little bit and uh,
we started with the monkey business
illusion and one of the things that's
really remarkable about the monkey
business illusion is that,
and change blindness experiments in
general is that they demonstrate to you
just to what degree you,
you could either describe yourself as
blind or focused.
And I think focused is actually better
than blind.
You know,
like a laser beam doesn't cover much
area,
but it really illuminates what it
strikes and people are sort of like that
were really beamed into a single point.
And there's something metaphysically
spectacular about that I think because
that single point that were narrowed
down to is in some thing some sense the
thing that rates the world,
you know,
because as we interact with the world,
we're able to turn it one way or another
in all sorts of complicated ways.
And I mean I know our powers and doing
so are obviously constrained to a,
to a substantial degree.
But by the same token,
that focal point of concentration
enables us to interact with the world.
And then at least seemingly to change it
according to our will,
which is,
you know,
it's like we take a future that's
potential and we interact with are the
focal point and then it transforms
itself into a past that's in some sense
fixed and real.
So that's pretty strange.
So I guess you know,
you wouldn't,
you don't want to underestimate the
utility of a point.
So I want to talk to you a little bit
first about what you're blind to and
then what this.
Much of what the consequences of that
are.
So this here is a little diagram of a,
of a computer,
believe it or not,
conceptual diagram of a computer and a,
it's predicated on.
I'll tell you a quick story.
If I've told you this story,
please stop me.
But I don't think I've told you guys
this story.
So one day back in about 1987,
I was working on my computer and I was
typing something
long essay in doth.
And you really had to backup in those
days because the programs didn't do any
backup for you.
And so if the thing shut off and you
hadn't been super careful,
you're just going to lose all of it.
So that's what happened.
I was typing away,
computer went off and so I had an
emotional reaction to that right now,
an emotional reaction.
That is kind of an interesting event
because I would say that you're not even
working with the computer until it
quits.
And the reason I would say that is
because if you think about it,
when the computer's functioning,
the fact that it's an extraordinarily
complicated device is basically
irrelevant to you.
What you're working with roughly
speaking is the screen,
but not really.
Not even the screen you're working with.
Maybe the phrase or the or even the word
that's presented on the screen,
you know you're typing the word phrase,
sentence,
paragraph,
essay,
and only out pass that domain of
consideration.
Do you start thinking about the hardware
technology that underlies what you're
doing?
You don't want to think about that at
all.
When something's working,
you don't have to see it.
And so that gives you a clue as to
consciousness.
Consciousness is a,
an error detecting and correcting
phenomena and you're not conscious of
things that are going well,
so you know,
which might explain to some degree why a
lot of our life seems to be made up of
suffering and all.
If things are going well,
it isn't exactly like you're happy if
things are going well,
you just don't notice when they're going
well.
Sometimes if they unexpectedly go well
then that makes you happy,
but otherwise it's just the same old
thing.
Even if it's amazing.
No,
I was yesterday I was eating breakfast
with my son and I was complaining about
the fact that I have eat canned tuna
because I don't really like fish,
but I have to eat fish for a variety of
different reasons and I thought,
Jesus,
what are you complaining about?
I mean really you don't have tuna is
like most things are like,
they're like small whales,
right?
They weighed 600 pounds.
They're impossible to count.
So there's some poor characters out
there hauling in tuna,
which is impossible.
Then they have to clean them and freeze
them and smoke them and can them and
all.
I have to do is go to the store to pick
up this can of tuna and then I can
complain about it for breakfast.
It's like,
it's really quite staggering,
you know,
the fact that I can even ever eat a tuna
is a complete bloody miracle,
but it's not the sort of thing that
makes me happy because,
you know,
I just expect that which is very
pathetic,
but that's how it goes.
So anyways,
back to the computer.
So it stops working well and I would say
that's when I noticed the computer and
there's nothing more annoying than
noticing the computer when you're in the
middle of writing an essay because what
the hell do you know about computers and
own nothing?
What are you going to do?
Turn it on and off.
Well,
that's a problem solving process.
Number one,
write.
It usually works,
thank God,
but then if it doesn't work well then
you're into either the software or the
hardware.
So anyways,
I turned it on and off of that didn't
work.
And so then I turned on light to see if
I could see,
you know,
if something had happened at the back of
it,
but the light didn't go on so then I
thought a half the power of probably
went out or I blew a fuse so went and
looked to see if the fuse was burned
out,
but it wasn't.
And then I noticed that all the power
and the house was off and then I noticed
that I went outside down to the corner
store to get something.
I don't remember what.
And then I knew when I went outside I
noticed that all the street lights were
off and then the entire power grid in
Montreal and was on.
And then the entire power grid for like
half of Quebec was out and a big chunk
of eastern North America.
And do you know why have I told you this
story?
Good?
Because there was a solar flare.
And so you know,
the,
the sun is a big hydrogen bomb,
right?
So I don't know if you guys know this is
cheerful piece of information for you if
you need to be cheered up.
But if you had to have a hydrogen bomb
and you exploded it,
you know,
a hydrogen bomb has an atom,
bomb courts trigger pool.
Did you guys know that?
You need to know that because it's
important because an atom bomb is a big
thing,
right?
But it's just a trigger for a hydrogen
bomb.
So a hydrogen bomb is unimaginably
bigger than that and Adam ball anyways.
If you blew a hydrogen bomb in the
atmosphere over central North America,
you could probably wipe out maybe all of
the electronic equipment in the entire
continent permanently.
Because what happens is when a hydrogen
bomb goes off,
there's an electromagnetic burst and has
that propagates,
it'll hit your electronic equipment and
propagate across the wires and produce a
big spike in current voltage,
I think.
And it'll just low it.
So your car was,
were your tractors won't work,
your work,
your cars won't work,
your computers won't work,
your satellites won't work.
It's done.
And also,
just to cheer you up even more,
back in the late 18 hundreds,
I think it was in the 18 sixties,
there was this,
uh,
uh Oh.
Let's go back to the sun.
So the sun is a big hydrogen bomb and
now and then it freaks out and emits no,
a big solar flare,
which is something that's gone wrong on
the sun and maybe it flows out the solar
flare almost to the,
you know,
the,
uh,
orbit of mercury.
And then that burst of radiation comes
zooming towards earth and then nine
minutes later it hits and if it's a
decent electromagnetic pulse than it'll
wipe up the power grid and come back.
And that's what happened.
So,
so the reason my computer didn't work
was because the son was misbehaving and
so,
so I liked that it was very illuminating
to me because it just shows you how many
things have to be stacked on top of each
other working perfectly for some thing
that you're doing to actually function.
So anyways,
back in the late 18 hundreds in the 18
sixties,
there was a massive solar flare and it
produced a burst of power on the
telegraph lines and it lit some
telegraph operators on fire.
And so this does happen.
It happens about once a century.
And we just missed one last year.
So while you're worrying about global
warming,
you can be,
you can be considering the much higher
probability that a solar flare,
we'll knock out all of our electronics
and send us to like 1860.
So the point is,
is that a lot of,
first of all,
but there's a lot of things going on to
make up an object that you don't detect
with your vision.
You know,
like you never think,
well the reason that the computer works
is because the sun is,
you know,
acting properly.
But it is of course the case that
endless numbers of things have to be
stabilized that you don't see.
And you might say,
well the sun isn't part of the computer,
but well that's wrong.
It's not part of the computer in some
sense when it's behaving.
But as soon as it stops behaving,
it's instantly part of the computer,
you know?
And then so here we've got
no.
And then you might say,
well,
let's say the power hadn't gone out in
the computer,
stopped working and well then you might
think,
well I'll never buy that brand again.
You know,
and maybe the brand is associated with,
you know,
the operation in some country where
corruption is rife and things are made
in properly in the parts don't work very
well.
So you might think,
well I made a stupid purchase decision
and of course that's connected to the
political system of that place and the
economy and you know,
and then weird little things can happen
down at the micro level as well as the
macro level.
So computers have now got.
So the chips have now got so small,
you know,
they have little wires in them,
right?
The chips,
the wires now so small that because of
quantum uncertainty.
So quantum uncertainty basically tells
you that if you can't really tell how,
where an electron is,
if you want to know how fast it's going
and you can't tell how fast it's going,
if you want to know where it is,
but more than that,
it also says you can't really know where
the baby is.
And so what that means is that once you
get your wire short enough,
some of the electrons might not be in
the wires where they're supposed to be
at the actually cause short circuits.
So that's another issue.
There's other levels of reality that are
micro levels that you can't detect it
all.
So there's macro levels that are way
beyond you,
you know,
political systems,
economic systems,
biological systems,
physical systems outside of that.
And then there are these microsystems
layered all the way down and things can
go wrong at any one of those levels.
And,
and a lot of Max invisible to us.
You know,
the same thing happens when something
goes wrong with you.
You know,
it's like what's wrong with you?
Maybe you're,
you're malfunctioning at the molecular
level,
your DNA isn't working properly.
So you get cancer or maybe some virus
which is even smaller than the DNA comes
in and takes up residence in that that's
really not so good.
Or you know,
maybe maybe you're eating something
wrong and you have an organ malfunction
or,
or maybe your family is screwed up and
you're stressed half to death.
And the reason they're screwed up is
because of your liver,
let's say a radically a society that's
not friendly to your particular
immigrant type.
And so the real reason that you're sick
is because of,
you know,
people's inability to get along with one
another and so on and so forth and so
on.
And so God only knows where you're
supposed to focus,
but focus,
we do.
And one of the things that,
um,
motivation allows you to do is to figure
what you're going to focus on.
Now you think,
God,
there's all these things to focus on.
There's an infinite number of things to
focus on.
How in the world do you ever figured out
how to focus on anything?
Well,
the answer to that is evolution.
Fundamentally,
it's like
you can view evolution in the following
way.
You know,
there's,
you can kind of think about the
background of reality.
I think the best way to think about if
it has this interplay of patterns,
complex patterns,
sort of like music and those patterns
are always changing and that sort of
dynamic weight.
And they exist at multiple levels just
like complex music does.
So then imagine that you're trying to do
is to
to dance to the music,
to align yourself to the music and it
keeps changing on you.
And so well,
what do you do?
Well,
if you can change that,
you can change for the music,
but if you can change then that's it.
You're not dancing anymore.
Okay.
So let's assume that there's two ways of
solving that problem.
One way is just sheer number.
You're a single celled organism or a
mosquito and you don't have that much
neural capacity for transformation.
And so you don't know what the melody is
going to be when you,
when you lay your eggs,
if you're a mosquito.
And so you produce like a million eggs
and some of them can dance to the
current beat and the others camp and so
they all die.
And so that's what happens over the
course of evolution for a very,
very long time.
The melody keeps changing and then what
creatures do is propagate a whole
variety of variance of themselves.
And in the case of like small animals or
fish even or crayfish or that sort of
thing,
you know,
they just overproduce offspring like mad
and hope that one of them can dance to
the current tune and then,
you know,
we get three and a half billion years
later,
roughly speaking here,
we all are.
And what we've got is this dynamic
nervous system and it enables us to take
an external pattern and map it to a
neurological pattern or multiple
neurological patterns because we can
interpret things right?
And then to output that to multiple
behavioral patterns.
And so in some sense what we've done is
we've internalized the process of
evolutionary variation into ourselves
and the Camorra complex.
Roughly speaking,
the more layers your nervous system has
imagined,
there's a pattern on your skin and then
that's interpreted by a pattern of
nerves.
And then those nerves have an output
there.
Sensory nerves will say,
then those have an output to motor
nerves.
And then how those have an output to
muscles.
That's you roughly.
You know,
you're maybe a four layer thing in that
regard,
but then you grow all these extra layers
of neural tissue,
you know,
so that the layers are hundreds of
cells,
thick,
one hundreds of layers thick,
and then you can map a whole bunch of
patterns in the external world onto a
whole bunch of patterns in the neuro
world and then onto a whole bunch of
patterns in the motor world and so that
makes you dynamically adaptable.
But you learned all that through this
incredibly painful process of evolution,
which basically consisted of the death
of like 99 point nine,
nine,
nine percent of everything that ever
lived.
Species and individuals alike.
So now why is that relevant?
Well,
how do you figure out how to focus in on
something?
Well,
a big part of that is actually,
let's see how we do it.
Well,
first of all,
what are you focusing on in here?
Well,
not poisonous snakes and you know,
rampaging lions and chimpanzees because
they're not in here.
And the reason they're not in here,
roughly speaking,
is because while you live in a culture
that's very,
very highly advanced and it's got walls
like mad,
this is a carcassone I think of a French
city of medieval city.
It's still exists.
Beautiful City.
You'll see how the medieval people solve
this problem.
It's like,
well,
you can't deal with much.
Okay,
well what do we do?
Build some walls,
keep a bunch of stuff out.
You don't have to worry about the
rampaging barbarians then because they
just can't get in.
And so a lot of the reason that you can
handle the insane complexity of the
world is because it's not even
neurological,
right?
It has virtually nothing to do with your
physiology.
It's just that you're,
you know,
you're,
you're in a university and the
university is protected by the city and
the city is protected by the province
and the province is protected by the
country and the country is protected by
its know all of its multiple
entanglements and you're just,
you're inside walls,
inside walls,
inside walls and so on.
And so your role is pretty simple.
You can just sit there in relative
warmth and comfort and not have to worry
about anything.
So that's one solution.
There's a cultural solution,
man.
You know,
inside the cultural solution,
obviously there's architectural
solutions of various sorts and then
there's political and economic
institutions that are pretty stable and
they keep you from having to deal with
chaos.
I mean you could see that chaos breaking
out a little bit in the previous weeks,
right in the American election because
the trump people in the left wingers are
going at it at the trump rallies and you
know,
you can see that's just tinder.
That could just blow up at any point.
And then all of that protection that's
there because of these very complex
games that we've agreed to play,
like the democracy game,
you know,
that just all flies by the wayside and
all of a sudden you have to content with
what people are like and that is not
something you want to do.
Those people,
they they're capable of anything which
is good but also really bad.
Well then the next thing is you've got a
body now.
That's where the evolutionary process
really kicks in and so your.
The reason your body is the way it is
roughly speaking is because it's
mimicked the external environment,
so just like you know,
piaget talks about children using their
bodies to mimic the external
environment.
You know,
voluntarily your body is set up through
this evolutionary process so that you
could focus on precisely that subset of
things.
That seems to keep something like you
going for long enough for you to make
another one,
something that's more or less like you
and you know that it only really works
for about 100 years.
That's pretty much where it pops out and
so you don't solve the problem very
well.
You don't solve the problem of radical
complexity very well,
but you solve it well enough so that you
live long enough to reproduce.
Speaking strictly biological and that
appears to be good enough and part of
the reason why you seem to expire
because you might think,
well if I evolution,
it's like why don't people just live for
like 500 years instead of 100 years?
You know,
because you think that
someone who could continue to reproduce
for 200 years instead of 100 years would
have it all over someone who could only
manage it for 50 years say,
but it turns out that your genes have a
better time of it if you just put them
into a new body
and shuffle off this mortal coil so
you're not using up too many resources
while your children and grandchildren
are trying to,
you know,
survive.
And so that's an evolution.
You've got to,
that's an evolutionary solution.
It's not.
Death is not technically inevitable.
There are creatures that are roughly
immortal gold fish for example,
which is really annoying.
So like really goldfish because their
cart and cart basically just keep
growing and it isn't obvious that they
sent us or,
or age they get killed because they get,
they get diseases and this sort of
thing.
But you know,
there are 300,
400 year old carp and some turtles seem
to not a age really.
And you know,
and then of course your DNA is being
there for ever since life started.
So it doesn't really age either.
And it corrects itself so things can
last a very,
very long time,
but,
but not us.
So anyways,
were put inside of this floor and he
frames things for us and starts
narrowing things down.
In this,
you know,
our psychophysiological cells have a
limited range of interests and desires
and needs,
however you want to construe that,
you know,
and then that gets instantiated more
into the nervous system.
And you know,
it's a mistake to think people always
think your brain is in your head.
And that's really not a very bright way
of thinking about it.
I don't know exactly why we think that
way because while there's the nervous
system,
you can see it right there.
There's a lot of your nervous system
that's not in your head.
The,
you know,
the volume,
the motor and sensory systems are
distributed throughout your body.
Your spine is smart enough so that if it
gets severed and we put you over top of
a treadmill,
suspend you,
you can walk,
you don't know you're walking and you
can't control it,
but your legs,
we'll do a perfectly good job of walking
without you being involved at all.
So your spine is brain tissue for all
intents and purposes.
You're brain is distributed through your
body.
And so,
and then you know,
it's evolved so that it's pretty good at
going around specifying what it needs.
And so,
you know,
we talked about the hypothalamus the
other day.
That was it and how it,
you know,
accounts for what I called
subpersonalities that are motivated
towards particular ends.
And those ends are,
you know,
obviously the things that we would
identify as fundamental biological
necessities,
but then they transformed themselves as
we interact socially into more and more
complex fundamental biological
necessities.
You know,
you.
Because it's,
it's a tricky thing because people talk
about needs as if they're biologically
instantiated.
You know,
like they're the fundamental building
elements of motivation.
But it's not really that obvious a.
because you know,
you might say,
well,
being hungry as a biological need,
but being a doctor isn't,
well not really because you know,
if you do end up being a physician,
you pretty much solve the food
acquisition problem permanently,
right?
So it's just a higher order
manifestation of the same thing and it's
higher order because instead of just
eating once you eat everyday for the
next 40 years and instead of just
feeding you,
you feed you and your family and maybe
some other people too.
So thinking of that as something that
isn't rooted in biology is not accurate.
It's,
it's a kind of a continuous
complexification from the,
from the simple local time bound,
a
immature subpersonalities that can only
fulfill themselves in this moment and
with help to the development of those
circuits,
which I would say is your personality
that are capable of providing you with
what you need in order to live and to be
attractive to other people across very
large spans of time.
It's like a tree,
you know,
it's like a tree expanding upward.
So good.
It's a good metaphor.
So.
All right,
so that's fine.
So that's motivation sets up your
perceptual frame and so people often
talk about motivation as if it's a drive
or a need,
something,
not that those terms are particularly
well defined.
A drive I suppose is a deterministic
sequence of motor output,
something like that,
but it's not accurate because the
motivation actually it specifies what
you look at and specifies right what you
see it's.
And then it specifies as well what
you're going to respond to emotionally.
So just imagine this.
Say I'd offered a $10,000 prize for the
person who counts the number of
basketballs correctly and then you know
you're doing your best to count the
number of basketballs in the monkey
illusion and somebody stands up in front
of you like this and blocks your view.
Well,
what emotion are you going to feel?
Negative emotion,
right?
In all likelihood.
And so that might be anxiety because
you're not going to win.
It might be fear or anxiety because
you're not going to win,
but also fear because what the hell is
this crazy person doing anger,
right?
That's another negative emotional
though.
There's a positive attack element to it.
You know,
um,
frustration,
disappointment,
maybe some grief,
like a whole,
I'm differentiate mess of negative
emotions.
Well,
why?
in some sense the motivational system
specifies the map and the,
and the goal.
It's a little more complicated though
because it also specifies where you are,
but it's like you can think about it as
a map with a,
with a destination.
That's why stories are like that,
you know,
because we inhabit Lumax Max like that
all the time.
And then what emotions do,
roughly speaking is telling you whether
or not things are going the way you want
them to as you're on that path.
And so the emotions in some sense have
to have a motivational specification
before their,
uh,
before they're properly functional.
Like,
what should you get angry at?
Well,
generally you get angry at things that
either interfere with your progression
towards a valued goal or upset the
entire.
Some personality,
you know,
that,
that contains the goal itself.
That's a more,
that's a more,
uh,
what would you call it?
That's a more serious failure.
You know,
if you have to,
it's one thing to fail when you're
trying to do something.
It's another thing to fail so hard you
have to give up the whole project.
We would rather just fail at sub sub
element then have to give up the whole
project.
Right?
It's one thing to fail an exam,
it's another thing to fail out of
university.
So,
and you know,
I think the reason for that,
I thought about that for a long time.
Why is it worse to fail out of
university?
Assuming you want to be in university
then it is to fail an exam.
How does your brain compute that?
No,
because you can't tell all the
consequences,
right?
So it's not self evident,
but it seems to me that it's something
like,
you think about these,
these functional subpersonalities as
having a temporal and spacial range of
application.
So if you're a university student,
if you're sort of stabilized for like
four years,
right?
Wherever you go,
you can say,
people say,
well,
what do you do?
And you can say,
I'm a university student and everybody's
happy about that.
You know,
from an economic perspective,
it's probably worse than being
unemployed,
right?
In some sense and,
but if you can't just go tell people
that you're unemployed and then you have
a nice little high status slot in
society,
it doesn't work that way,
but you can do that as a university
student,
you know,
so it fulfills your social obligations
and it makes you feel like you're doing
something at least vaguely useful and
you know,
I mean apart from the learning and all
the other things that are positive about
it.
So what happens is,
is that map basically covers a space and
time.
The time is four years in the space is
everywhere.
You go during those four years and then
if that map burns up,
it's like you're exposed on all fronts
for that entire four year period and
that might even be the two years
previously.
Right.
For example,
because it's strange to think that,
but if you bail out of university
halfway through your third year,
you've also structured the map that you
use to organize your memories in some
sense of the previous two and a half
years.
Right?
Because first of all,
they were the memories of someone who's
doing just fine and going through
university and now all of a sudden
they're the memories of someone who
failed.
Those aren't the same memories.
And so it's weird that you know,
it's weird that an error can alter the
past,
but,
but you can and often does,
I mean break any relationship breakup
that's of any significance will do
exactly the same thing.
Especially if you are trading right.
It's like it's not just the present and
the future that dissolve into chaos and
take you on a little trip to the
underworld.
It's also your revision.
You're the necessity of revising your
past.
So anyways,
so then I would say,
well,
failing a class while the class will be
structured,
you in some sense and focuses you for a
certain subset of the general going to
university map.
So it's going to be less traumatizing to
do poorly on a class than it is to fail
out of university because the amount of
space and time that goes respective maps
covers differs.
And so what you're trying to do always
is to lay out under a functional game
that's a good way of thinking about it
on the spacetime territory that you
inhabit.
And if you understand that,
then you can start to understand a
little bit about emotions.
So let's,
yeah,
now,
okay,
I have to put a little Coda in there.
And that's the motivations and emotions
are not technical terms.
There's sort of like in an ego,
you know,
their,
their turns that you can use to
structure a debate.
Like I showed you the hypothalamus and
you see it's made out of the Volvo's
little nuclei.
They're not the same.
So you can't say that every part of the
hypothalamus is doing something that you
can fit into a class.
Motivation and motivations and emotions
overlap.
So,
you know,
I would say hunger.
That seems to be some of them overseeing
more purely motivation.
You know,
like if you have a,
an unsettling altercation with someone
at tends not to make you hungry now.
Whereas it might make you angry,
it might make you happy,
it might make you sad,
you know,
so hunger is something that seems to pop
up,
one of these maps and then emotions
guide your way through it or telling you
where you are on it,
but then you have complex motivation,
emotions like pain and also anger
because pain has a goal in it,
right?
Get away,
but it's also,
or stop or get away.
It's usually get away,
but it also has an emotional feeling,
right?
It feels bad.
And so it feels like an emotion.
Pain.
Grief is like pain.
Disappointment is like pain.
So,
um,
loneliness is like paint and I mean this
technically all of those things can be
addressed rather successfully with
opiates by the way.
So technically they're the same,
but pain you can't really be like,
is being hurt in emotion.
While people will say that,
I feel hurt,
whatever.
And anger is another one of those that
sort of ambivalent because anger has a
goal,
right?
It's like
remove obstacle removed or destroyed
obstacle in a sense.
That's the goal of anger.
But people talk about it as an emotion,
so we're oversimplifying,
it doesn't matter because it's useful
oversimplification and that sort of what
a theory is.
Ready,
useful oversimplification.
So all right,
so
I kind of laid out what I think are the
basic motivations there.
Hunger,
thirst,
pain,
anger,
thermal regulation.
You don't want to be too hot or too
cold.
Panic or escape,
affiliation or care,
sexual desire,
exploration play,
and you can kind of divide those into
self maintenance motivations and south
propagation motivations.
Roughly speaking,
I'm sort of just a way to keep track of
them.
And then emotions.
So the hypothalamus is involved in law
that it's not the only thing but it's
involved in a lot of that.
So here's sort of how I've
conceptualized one of these maps and
we've seen this thing before.
You're,
you're at point a because if you're
using a map or if you're in a game,
you know there's a starting point or
you're a player.
Either way there's you there and then
you're going somewhere,
right?
And you have to do something to get
there.
Okay?
So that's the little map and maybe you
have to go make a peanut butter sandwich
or you have to turn the thermostat down
or you need to call your friend or
whatever,
but it's,
it's the same kind of structure that
you're using in all those different
situations.
And they switch,
you know,
now you're finished being hungry,
now you're thirsty.
Then your lonesome,
you know,
it's like it says if this,
it's one,
it's one damn thing after another,
roughly speaking.
And so that's what keeps you alive and
you have to be chasing things all the
time because your natural tendency is to
run out of fuel and became.
And so that's entropy.
You have to fight that.
And so that's a continual battle because
you're pretty organized and it's really
hard for something that organized to
just stay organized.
You know,
it's a lot easier.
There's a million ways to mess up your
route.
There's like one way to clean it or
maybe 10 years,
but you get the point.
So then it's the same with anything
that's extraordinarily complex.
There's not that many ways it can stay
order.
And there's a lot of ways it can fall
apart,
so that's why you're running all the
time on a treadmill.
You're fighting the second.
Is it the second law of thermodynamics?
Is entropy the second law of
thermodynamics?
I think so,
that's a major one.
So you know,
good luck in your scrap because
you're going to need it.
So.
So all of these little underlying
biological systems pop up the primary
maps and then those are elaborated
upward into maps that are more and more
complicated and the more and more
complicated maps maybe solve two
problems at the same time for a week or
they solve 10 problems at the same time
for 20 years.
That's why you want a job or a career,
right?
I mean the whole bunch of problems are
solved all immediately as soon as you're
employed.
So I mean you have some other problems
but.
But that's inescapable anyways.
Okay.
So you're inside one of these so you're
always motivated.
You're always running around after
something.
And you know,
that's another thing to know too,
because the basic state of human beings
is not quite essence.
You know,
you're not napping in front of a
fireplace.
If you're not pursuing something that
you're motivated to pursue,
then generally what you're doing is
figuring out how to pursue other things
that you're motivated to pursue.
And that's exploration.
So if you're not actively motivated by,
by biological necessity will say for the
sake of simplicity,
then the next motivation kicks in is
which well,
prepare for the next time that you're so
motivated and that really accounts for
our capacity to explore and we're always
zooming around the world and trying to
figure out what to do with it next,
you know,
acquiring more information or even when
we're entertaining ourselves because we
almost always looking at stories when we
entertain ourselves.
We're still acquiring the information
that has functional significance and so
attractive to us that we find it
innately rewarding just to observe that
sort of thing.
So it's even in strange situations like
people will go to horror movies.
It's like,
what?
What's wrong with,
uh,
you know,
the why do you want to go get scared or
disgusted because that's horror,
right?
Fear and disgust that this plane
uncertainty,
horror movies like the Blair witch
project,
that's pretty much all fear and then you
know,
the slasher movies and that sort of
thing,
that's pretty much all discussed and you
might say,
well why bother exposing yourself to
that and part of it is get over it.
No,
it's exposure because life has
terrifying elements and it has
disgusting elements and you're going to
have to learn to,
to maintain yourself in the face of
that,
you know,
I mean certainly illness is going to
challenge your capacity to deal with
disgust and you know,
there's any number of reasons to be
terrified.
So you go to movies and you practice
facing.
Then you observed that you can know and
I mean there's other motivations too,
but those are the sort of the healthy
ones that go along with people wanting
to expose themselves to dangerous
situations.
So.
So even in that you see exploration in
the preparation for what's going to
happen next and the exploratory circuits
and very,
very fundamental circuit.
It's also hypothyroid,
ironically mediated.
So the way the hypothalamus works,
it's quite cool,
is that
on one hand it pops up all these little
maps that you can occupy that did have,
the court will say biological
necessities,
so roughly Freud's id,
but when those things all shut down
because they're satiated,
that's a technical term by the way,
satiated.
It means satisfied and it's a form of,
it's a form of reward,
you know,
so it sort of how you feel after you've
eaten a good meal and you're in a warm
room and your friends around you,
you know,
maybe you'd go to sleep if it's your
family,
you know,
because I'm thinking about Thanksgiving
or something like that.
It's just everything is taken care of.
And so we fall asleep.
That's sort of that satiation.
You can see that now and almost all the
time because they spend a lot of time
seizuring dogs,
they sleep a lot,
cats,
they sleep a lot because you know,
they've already attacked her cat food.
So that's pretty much it for the day.
So human beings,
you know,
we tend not so much to enter into states
of satiation.
Now,
what happens when,
when you're,
when you're in one of those little
units,
you know,
one of those little motivated things,
there's a couple of things that can
happen.
Got It.
Here.
The next one probably.
Yeah.
This is good.
Hmm.
Okay.
So we talked about motivation.
So as sort of setting up this,
just a little frame and then we can talk
about emotions.
So there you're going somewhere and
there was this little straight line
that'll take you there.
It's nice,
efficient way to get there.
Now why do you want to do it
efficiently?
Well,
because you use up the least amount of
resources so then you can maintain some
resources for doing the next thing that
you need to do.
So you care about efficiency and
simplicity.
So you want to go like the crow flies to
the destination.
And so then what,
what happens along the way?
Well,
let's say you just get to go straight
while basically what happens is that
you're motivated by your perception of
the goal or intermediary goals because
the goals can be linked together and
then as long as things are going
according to plan,
you know as you move towards the goal in
an untrammeled way,
you're going feel mild positive emotion
and the reason for that is is that
you're turning the environment the
environment almost never has.
Most of it's irrelevant.
The rest of it has a positive or
negative valence,
and if things are going according to
plan,
it has a mild positive valence,
right?
You think things are okay and really
what you're doing is you're observing
two things.
You're observing that the things that
should be happening,
if you know what you're doing while
you're acting are happening,
and so each step forward is an
indication that
you're getting closer to your goal.
That's incentive reward.
That's incentive reward,
and that's the sort of reward that you
actually think of as fun and incentive.
Reward is produced by activation of the
exploratory system that's in the
hypothalamus.
It has its roots in the hypothalamus and
that's the dopaminergic system and
that's the system that cocaine and
amphetamines and all those other drugs
that people really like to take
hyperactivates,
making them feel like they're doing
something important and useful even
though they're not so the dopaminergic
drugs in some sense,
hijack your incentive reward systems and
it's incentive reward because you're
incentivized to continue moving forward.
Anything that you look at that makes you
want to touch it or move forward to it
basically activates the dopaminergic
system.
So now,
so you say,
well,
what happens when you're on your way to
somewhere?
Well,
roughly what happens is neutral things,
which is okay.
You can ignore them,
positive things or negative things,
positive things happen when things are
going according to plan or even better
than according to plan.
You know you're walking to school,
it's raining.
Somebody you know stops and offers you a
lift.
It's like,
oh,
you're doing okay getting to school and
that was fine,
but all of a sudden you're getting there
a little faster and you're not getting
wet,
so at cheers you up.
It's an indication that you're able to
save the resource as well.
You're moving towards a goal,
open the we mediated and then we could
imagine a different scenario where
you're walking to school in the rain and
somebody drives by you.
Maybe it's even the same friend and they
don't see you and there's a puddle right
beside you and not only do they not
start,
but they completely cover you with oily
and frigid water and so you know that's
not so good.
You're angry about that and upset why?
Well,
your day is,
you might say,
my day is ruined.
What does that mean exactly?
Well,
it means that you had a little map on
top of your day and you were hoping that
the day and the map would correspond and
then all of a sudden the map burned up
and god only knows what's going to
happen to the day and so it's like the
bottom has dropped out your map and so
and then you have to worry about your
clothes and catching cold and all those
things and turning around and going home
and what it will mean if you miss class
and so on and so forth.
So basically that's the domain of chaos
that we talked about.
So that's a negative thing,
but it's also the thing about negative
things is there sort of hard to
disentangle from unexpected things,
you know,
because most of the things that happened
to you that are negative are also
unexpected because you don't go around
trying to make negative things happen so
well.
What happens when something negative
happens while you get a negative
emotion?
Pain,
anxiety discussed.
Those seem to be the big three and
they're mediated by different systems.
We don't understand the disgust system
very well.
It doesn't load with neuroticism,
which is quite weird because all the
other negative emotions is load on
trait.
Neuroticism,
pain,
pain seems to be what you experienced.
If you're receptive,
surfaces are,
you know,
if your physiological self is subject to
stimulation of an intensity that's
sufficient either to developing to
damage it or to damage the receptors so
you know,
but pain is complicated.
It's not just physical pain from
physical damage.
It depends on how you define physical
damage.
If someone dies that pain,
if you're alone and isolated,
that's paid.
If you're depressed,
that's paint.
If you're frustrated or disappointed,
that's pain.
Frustrated might mean something gets in
the way of you moving towards a goal and
disappointment might be in the whole
damn structure just collapsed on you.
Either way,
that's pain now,
that's,
you know,
the behaviors would have called that an
unconditioned,
like a painful stimulus.
They would've called that an
unconditioned stimulus.
You don't have to learn for that to be
bad.
It's sort of built in bad and they would
think about anxiety in response to the
unexpected as learned.
So the tech like the behaviors would
think that you need to learn what
predicts something painful and if you
learn that something predicts something
painful,
then you get anxious to it or afraid of
it.
So,
but it turns out that it's more
complicated than that so that we know
what the behaviors would think is that
pain in some senses,
the fundamental negative emotion.
And then you know,
maybe you're a kid and you,
you,
you stand up underneath the table and
you whack your head on it when you're
learning to walk.
And then when you go under the table,
now you get anxious because you've
learned that if you stand up under the
table,
you bang your head in.
That hurts.
And so anxiety under those circumstances
that learned behavior,
it's a conditioned response.
Got It,
okay.
But it's,
it's more complicated than that because
anxiety can also be an unlearned
response.
So if you just encounter something
you've never seen before,
it's going to make you anxious.
And there's actually a circuit that
mediates anxiety.
So it's not just a secondary derivation
of the pain circuitry,
it's its own little unit,
and it's sort of like you figured out
over time,
over evolutionary time,
not to get hurt because you know you
don't want to be damaged,
but then you've,
you've learned how to detect the
probability that you will get hurt for
so long that you've also evolved a
system just to respond to that.
And so some of that response to things
that you have learned are dangerous.
Some of it responds to things that are
generally dangerous,
blonde spiders,
uh,
in insects of various sorts,
facial expressions that indicate fear or
disgust or anger.
I'm broken.
Limbs bodies especially mutilated.
Once you know,
you can think,
you know what's in horror movies,
that's all sort of primary fear stimuli,
right?
And it's built right into now.
Psychologists debate about whether it's
bird built in or whether you can just
learn it really easily.
But I would say there's sort of a
continuum.
Some of it seems pretty damn built in
snake fear.
For example,
chimps who've never seen snakes,
you bring one into their cage.
It's a rubber snake.
Poof,
they hit the roof and then they look at
it and snakes in the wild,
a chimp will go up to his big snake in
the wild and who data,
if they have this special snake,
they called a snake wrapped to look at
the thing and some of them will just
look at the snake for like 24 hours so
you know,
partly they're afraid of it partner,
they want to explore it and so what they
do,
they get close to it and the fear
increases and then they back up and the
fear decreases and the curiosity
increases.
So what happens is they move back and
forth until they're right on the line
where they're afraid but they're curious
and so then they're stuck and they're
looking at it and you,
you experienced that all the time
actually because when you are engaged in
something that's meaningful,
that's where you are and that's like the
line between order and chaos.
You know,
because you want to solve and it's
important leader.
You are,
I don't know,
maybe you're reading papers about some
illness that you hope to work on her
study.
It's like,
well,
you're worried about the damn illness,
you know all you're doing is confronting
it through the paper so you know you're
fairly well sheltered from it,
but you don't want it to exist and you'd
rather it wasn't around,
but you're curious so you're going to
get engrossed in it,
and most of you,
to the degree that you're immersed in
anything are part immersed because you
perceive it as a problem,
so you know that's like existential
anxiety in a sense.
It's like it's just part of being.
There's problems that have to be solved.
They produce anxiety,
they're complicated.
You find this,
you find a way of approaching them so
that the anxiety doesn't overwhelm you,
and so the curiosity is optimized.
That's an incentive reward activation
and then you're awake because the
anxiety keeps you awake and so does the
curiosity and you think,
yeah,
this is a good place to be and it is a
good place to be because you're.
You're optimally protected right there
and you're optimally learning.
So yes,
that's a good place to be.
You could think about that as an answer
to the Nietzschean problem of how you
create value.
You don't exactly created,
you find it.
There's problems that need to be solved.
They automatically engage your emotions
both positively and negatively.
You've got to find the right balance.
And it's something like contending,
you know,
it seems to me that human beings have to
have something to contend with or they
can't tolerate themselves,
you know,
because life seems like a stupid joke if
you don't have something worthwhile to
do,
but you could have something worthwhile
to do.
And so then maybe it's not so stupid and
observed and tragic and that's at least
a good way to think about it.
So you've got satiation on the one hand,
on the positive side and the behaviors
would have considered that an
unconditioned response to.
They really thought about that and his
reward initially,
you know,
so you take a rat,
he's hungry,
you feed them something,
reward now skinner,
he used to train rats,
right?
And he was the,
he was,
he was a very,
uh,
what would you call it?
Very well renowned behavioral
psychologist.
And he could train routes to do damn
near anything and what he would do is
starve them to three quarters of their
body weight because then their damn
mode,
they are basically,
you know,
Hungry Rats,
they were hungry lonesome rats because
they lived at ice isolated existence
which rats don't like.
And then they would start going to three
quarters of their body weight.
So when,
when the behaviorist used rats as a
model for people,
they actually used poetry,
lonesome rats as a model for rats as a
model for people.
And you might think,
well,
what kind of model is that?
But it turns out it's pretty good bottle
because you're a lot more like a scared
hungry rat than you'd like to,
that you'd like to admit.
Which is partly why you can emphasize,
empathize with what?
Right.
Everybody sitting there thinking,
whoa,
over the poor rats.
By the way,
the more you thought that more agreeable
you are.
So how many people were feeling pretty
sorry for those rats.
Yeah.
So how about men?
How many men were feeling sorry for
those rats?
Oh yeah,
about three.
Yeah.
There's a big gender difference in
agreeableness between men and women by
the way,
so
just so you know,
we'll talk about that more so now the
behavior is also thought that you had
this primary set of rewards,
call them unconditioned,
and then you had to learn that some
things predicted them like,
oh,
classically,
maybe
rat and push a lever and get a pellet.
As soon as he's pushing that lever,
like Matt,
he's pretty happy about pushing that
lever.
Okay.
And he learned that conditioned
association between lever pushing and
getting a reward,
but it turns out that because that's
been around for so long,
you also have a system for it.
So it's not just a learned association
to what satiates you.
It's a whole system.
That's the dopaminergic system and it.
The serotonin system seems to be the
thing that satiates.
So you know,
if you have a big Turkey dinner,
it's like up goes the serotonin levels.
It's like you don't have to do anything,
and Serotonin is a calm,
a calming and regulating neurochemical,
which is why antidepressants stop your
neurons from taking up serotonin before
you've had a real chance to use it to
regulate your nervous system.
So but Dopa mean tells you,
hey,
good things are on their way and that's
pretty much what people run on and you
could think about that as hope.
So incentive reward is sort of like hope
or promise,
I think promises a better term.
So there's pain and satiation and those
are really ancient systems and then
there are newer systems that are an
anxiety and promise
and those are related to those more
fundamental negative and positive
emotions.
And those things regulate you while
you're on your path.
Now there's one more level of
complication because you think what can
happen on the way to your goal?
Nothing irrelevant.
Okay?
So that's,
that's the irrelevance that enables you
to not see the gorilla and almost
everything around you is irrelevant.
And I think that's partly why people
don't like to have their little maps of
the world destroyed because if your map
of the world is thoroughly demolished,
everything becomes irrelevant and you do
not want everything to become relevant.
It's just too much for you.
So you wake up and you're naked and it's
dark in the middle of a jungle.
It's like everything's relevant.
You're not going to like that.
It's going to burn me out quick.
And so most of the time you have to be
protected so that almost everything's
irrelevant.
And then you can focus on the few things
that you're capable of handling and you
do that so you're in your little map and
then as you move towards your emotions
play and the negative emotions appear
when things are not going well,
when the positive emotions appear,
when things are going well,
that's basically how your emotions work.
Now you've got your satiation and your
your pain,
then you've got your threat and your
promise,
and then on top of that you've gotten
more complicated thing,
which is novelty because that's the
other thing that can happen when you're
on the way from point a to point b,
something you didn't expect,
so what you don't understand,
so
you're walking down the street and
there's someone laying their face down
on the sidewalk
and you know they're this,
they're disheveled and so well,
what's your emotional response while you
didn't expect it?
So you're going to be taken aback that
that's anxiety.
It's like you're moving towards your
goal.
The anxiety stops you.
Now you could think of the space.
You could think of this space,
time area around that person as
unexplored territory.
Now you don't want any unexplored
territory in your map because God only
knows what's going to happen there.
Okay,
so what are you supposed to do?
Well,
maybe you cross the street.
You think,
well,
that person's drunk,
or maybe you think,
well,
they're a homeless person and they're
lying on a sleeping bag on just to
sleep.
You know you're going to be losing,
you're going to stop,
and then you're going to observe and
then you're going to use little cues to
try to put your map back together and
your map is what's going on here and
what should I do about it.
And so it's partly this interplay
between anxiety and curiosity.
Now you can just step around and
continue,
but maybe that'll upset your moral map.
What kind of personnel?
Mind you know,
maybe I should've done something about
it or maybe you think there's no damn
way I'm going to get involved in this
because you know,
who knows what'll happen if I step in
there and you know,
fair enough,
because who knows what will happen if
you step in there.
The point is is that it's like your map
which has made everything irrelevant.
It's got a hole in it and now some of
what's complicated is shining through
and that thing that's shining through.
So that's what the phenomenologists
talked about as shining forth.
That thing that's shining through.
It's like you don't know what to do
about it.
What should you do?
Well,
you,
you should do.
What you do do and what you,
what you do is you prepare to do
everything and that's an emotional
response to novelty.
It's like,
well,
if you don't know what to do,
you should prepare yourself for anything
and that that's stress.
You could prepare it and something good
will happen.
You know,
let's say in,
in,
in an ambivalent.